l'entrée en scène de l'équipe de france
dans moins d'une heure sur le stade
vélodrome de marseille la ville
électrisé mais le mistral joue les
trouble fête dans ce journal l'ambiance
dans la cité de idal la journée des
bleus et des supporteurs lionel jospin
joue la carte de la famille volte-face
il renonce à la mise sous condition des
allocations et propose rabaissement du
quotient familial une mesure qui
favorise les cloisons et elle le
procureur général de mandat non lieu
dans la sphère du sang contaminé pour
les trois ministres laurent fabius
georgina dufoix edmond hervé l'atacama
remet cette nuit dans la propriété du
parfumeur guerlain un commando a tiré
sur le gardien grièvement blessé jean
paul guerlain une balle dans la cuisse
se remet doucement la découverte par les
compagnons d'emmaüs d'un trésor dans un
immeuble de forbach est là kishon savoir
à qui reviendra ce butin composé de
pièces d'or et de billets de banque
la justice devra trancher madame
monsieur bonsoir à l'unisson le coeur
des français battra ce soir pour
l'entrée en jeu des bleus au stade de
vélodrome devant soixante mille
spectateurs
nous sommes tous un peu marseillais ce
soir prêt à vibrer à moins d'une heure
maintenant du coup d'envoi du match qui
opposera l'équipe de france aux bafana
bafana d'afrique du sud
une expérience unique pour la cité
phocéenne ambiance survoltée
mathieu chirurgie motte ce ballon n'a
rien d'un ballon de compétition mais sa
valeur est inestimable
il est béni des dieux
la bonne mère notre dame de la garde a
donné ce matin le coup d'envoi de la
coupe du monde à marseille metz coloré
et message de fraternité
une fraternité vérifier sur la canebière
où français et sud africains se
répondent chant français contre rythmes
zoulous
on a gagné la coupe d'afrique
il est temps de conquérir le monde seule
chose que nous devons faire maintenant
c'est soutenir mandela nous devons lui
offert un cadeau et ramener ce trophée
aux abords du stade les sud africains se
montrent les plus organisés et les plus
bruyants mais les marseillais restent
imperturbables décembre à mars est trop
la pression est possible et c'est vrai
que la pression monte
le jour est historique bientôt il faudra
chanter règle numéro 1 ne pas oublier de
se réhydrater voulez la guerre
psychologique entre supporters bientôt
place aux joueurs et pour ceux qui
n'auront pas trouvé de place au marché
noir
marseille offre ses plages son mistral
et ses écrans géants
aimé jacquet l'avait annoncé il ne
dévoilerai coup derniers instants la
composition de l'équipe qui affrontera
tout à l'heure l'afrique du sud
apparemment les joueurs étaient au
courant depuis ce matin mais nous ne
l'avons appris qu'il ya quelques minutes
une équipe de france qui se veut te
nique décomplexée et prête à briller dès
ce soir la journée des bleus yann lavoix
andré germain il est 17h30
l'heure des braves l'escort policière
sort de la résidence du moulin de
vernègues il précède le quart des
français qui fait route vers marseille à
60 km plus au sud
au même moment au stade vélodrome
des centaines de stadiers inspectent les
travées que derrière les buts
tout semble prêt pour accueillir le
public le plus coloré et le plus chaud
de france avec un public aussi est
chaleureux et enthousiaste que les
olympiens que les supporters marseillais
je crois qu on peut pas rêver mieux
aujourd'hui parce que ce sera le
douzième homme sur le terrain qui pourra
nous on est la force
idéal pour pouvoir aller au bout les
vestiaires sont simples des cintres des
bancs des divans de massage autant de
place que les français vont occuper pour
se concentrer avant le grand saut vers
la pelouse avant d'être aspirés par
l'événement il ya que de grands
professionnels chacun se prépare comme
il entend après moi c'est c'est plus des
petits mots des petites paroles à
travers l'échauffement
moi et les autres anciens évidemment
faire passer les dernières
recommandations le dernier message pour
pour être bien tous fixés sur le même
objectif
c'est ici le point de départ d'une belle
aventure c'est là que sera donné le coup
d'envoi
dans une heure nous retrouvons
maintenant à marseille
yann lavoix le mistral qui souffle en
rafales pourraient peut-être jouer les
trouble-fête le match va se dérouler en
effet dans des conditions climatiques
plutôt difficile oui béatrice le vent
souffle terriblement fort ici et depuis
ce matin le mistral a atteint parfois
des rafales de 110 120 kilomètres heure
inutile de vous dire qu'il va forcément
perturbé les conditions de ce match il y
avait un match de prévu même avant la
grande rencontre un match entre des
gamins en préambule il a même dû être
annulés c'est vous dire si le vent
souffle très très très fort en ce qui
concerne l'équipe qui devrait jouer ce
soir tout le monde ça
dans des avoirs les onze qui ont joué le
dernier match il y a une semaine de
préparation face à la finlande à
helsinki et bien non aimé jacquet nous a
réservé une petite surprise tout
simplement l'entrée en lice de thierry
henry la foudre l'ailier droit de l'as
monaco à la place de dugarry donc une
seule petite transformation elle est
taillé en attaque
enfin en ce qui concerne le public
regardez vous même béatrice bienvenue
sur la planète marseille
ils seront soixante mille fervents
supporters de l'équipe de france tout
simplement parce qu'ils ne veulent pas
manquer l'événement
un événement tout simple 12 ans 12 ans
que l'équipe de france n'a pas joué un
match de coupe du monde
alors ils ont hâte que ça commence et
nous aussi et puis en marge de cette
rencontre au stade de vélodrome tout à
l'heure la sphère de vente de billets
fantôme pour ce mondial de football qui
vient ternir la fête de milliers de
supporteurs qui ont été floués la
fédération internationale la fifa ouvre
deux enquêtes alors que de son côté le
comité français d'organisation se dit
prêt à saisir la justice
sébastien guibert frédéric masqué pour
le festival de cannes jacques lambert
directeur général du ces est faux a
peut-être quand même l'impression de
jouer dans un mauvais film
depuis plusieurs jours les supporters
brésiliens japonais belge qui se
retrouvent sans les billets déjà payé
accuse le comité d'organisation
aujourd'hui jacques lambert contre
attaque le c est faux a décidé de
dénoncer tous les faits dont il a
connaissance auprès du procureur de la
république de paris afin de permettre à
la justice d'entreprendre toute
poursuite judiciaire nécessaire fermeté
à l'égard d'abord des fédérations
nationales de football auquel le cf os
avaient fourni des placements
une enquête est ouverte sur la
fédération du cameroun dont le président
est depuis lundi mise en examen les
classes auraient été revendues à des
particuliers ou à des sociétés
mêmes soupçons à l'encontre de la
fédération de colons mais le cf aux
attaques aussi sévèrement les agences de
voyages notamment japonaises qui ont
multiplié ces derniers mois des offres
de billets qu'elle ne détenait pas
critiqué également les grands
tour-opérateurs pourtant choisi est
agréé par le cf os pour vendre les
places avec souvent billets d'avion et
chambre d'hôtel certains auraient eux
aussi promis plus de place qu'il n'en
avait jacques lambert s'est déclaré
aujourd'hui aux côtés des victimes tout
en craignant qu'elles soient de plus en
plus nombreuses au fil des jours bien
évidemment nous reviendrons largement
dans ce journal sur l'événement sportif
la première rencontre des tricolores
pour la coupe du monde en direct sur
france télévisions à val d'or 50 avec
des reportages des interventions
directes avant le coup d'envoi notre
rédaction et sur place l'actualité
aujourd'hui avec l'attak a marre mais
cette nuit dans la propriété du célèbre
parfumeur jean paul guerlain un commando
d'une dizaine d'hommes en cagoule armés
de fusils à pompe ont pendant plus de
quatre heures prise en otage le gardien
de la propriété les employés de maison
et l'homme d'affaires le parfumeur
blessé à la cuisse se remet lentement
agnès vahramian jacques gregor ils ont
la nuit dernière vécu quatre heures sous
la menace d'une arme
cet après midi l'un des gardiens de la
propriété guerlain et sa famille vient
enfin de livrer leur témoignage aux
gendarmes
hier ils étaient une vingtaine présents
dans la maison tous employés au service
du parfumeur jean paul guerlain lui
dormait dans sa chambre
lorsqu'une dizaine d'hommes sont arrivés
vers 23h30 le visage masqué c'est
d'ailleurs dans cette pièce située au
premier étage de la bâtisse que tous les
employés ont été tenus en respect
jusqu'à l'incident
chez guerlain a dû se saisir d'une arme
d'alarmé qui a effrayé les malfaiteurs
qui étaient qui était armée assez
puissamment de fusils à pompe et de
et d'armes de poing et qui ont à ce
moment là ça a déclenché une fusillade
une balle dans la jambe pour jean paul
guerlain et de dans le thorax pour le
régisseur du domaine un peu avant les
malfaiteurs s'étaient fait ouvrir les
coffres amassant leur butin donc
évidemment de l'argenterie ils ont
probablement pris de l'argent des bijoux
également mais on ne sait pas exactement
la réalité de du butin en plus peut-être
que l'ouverture du feu induit un départ
précipité alors qu'ils envisageaient la
base c'est autre chose dans sa propriété
jean paul guerlain possède de nombreux
tableaux de maîtres le parfumeur be le
plus souvent à paris et à l'évidence les
cambrioleurs étaient bien renseignés
mais les gendarmes exclut pour l'instant
toute complicité interne à la maison
guerlain
les triple analyses génétiques pratiquée
sur le corps d'yves montand et qui
démontre qu aurore drossart n'est pas la
fille du célèbre artiste ces tests
génétiques sont aujourd'hui contestée
par la mère de rohr qui se dit prête à
continuer le combat
valère est gagé les trois experts
mandatés par la justice sont formels
pour eux il est exclu qu aurore drossart
soit la fille d'yves montand trois
techniques de recherche moléculaire
différentes ont été employés et chaque
scientifique à vérifier plusieurs fois
ses résultats
sans se prononcer sur ce dossier précis
l'un des experts consultés explique que
l'embaumement d'un corps avec des
substances comme le formol n'enlève rien
à la validité des tests adn dans ce type
d' analyse c'est tout ou rien est une
façon générale soit aucun résultat et ce
résultat est exact soit on n'obtient pas
de résultats
donc si on obtient un résultat c'est que
l'adn n'a pas été modifiée par six ans
qu'elle soit d'ailleurs en dhr sarlat
mère d'aurore n'entend pas se satisfaire
de ces résultats
elle estime notamment que rien n'a été
fait pour identifier le corps d'yves
montand exhumé le 11 mars dernier son
avocat envisage de demander une contre
expertise
mais trois experts peuvent se tromper
s'ils utilisent des méthodes qui sont
critiqués alors on a l'impression que la
génétique aujourd'hui et la science
parfaite la lumière des lumière pénètre
dans l'ombre dans la nuit de la mort
elle va partout ce n'est pas vrai il y à
des contestations sur toutes sortes de
données apportées par la génétique il va
y avoir un débat sur la preuve par la
génétique
le rapport d expertise sera discutée
prochainement en présence des deux
parties en conflit
la cour d'appel de paris devrait rendre
son arrêt définitif avant la fin de
l'année dans l' affaire du sang
contaminé le procureur général de la
cour de cassation demande une nouvelle
fois un non lieu en faveur de laurent
fabius georgina dufoix edmond hervé les
trois ministres mise en examen en 92
pour complicité d'empoisonnement le
réquisitoire du procureur général
souligne les responsabilités du corps
médical
dominique verdeilhan lors de ses
auditions devant la cour de justice
laurent fabius n'a jamais varié dans ses
dépositions
pour le dépistage du sida j'ai pris la
décision qu'il fallait une ligne de
défense déjà développé en juillet 92
alors que l'ancien premier ministre
était appelée comme témoin au premier
procès du sang contaminé dans ses
réquisitions écrites jean-françois
burgevin le procureur général met hors
de cause laurent fabius mais aussi -et
dont hervé georgina dufoix
pour le magistrat aucune charge ne
justifie les poursuites pour complicité
d'empoisonnement contre les trois
ministres le procureur général conclut
que le gouvernement a agi dans des
délais conforme
sinon meilleur que ce qui a été fait
dans les autres pays
si et non hervé georges vient du foie
sont épinglés pour leur passivité ou
leur aveuglement ces réquisitions sont
surtout accablante pour les médecins
absence de concertation constante entre
les spécialistes défaut d'information ou
de formation des médecins soignant
conception étriquée de la pratique
médicale
enfin à propos de la polémique sur le
dépistage
le gouvernement at il volontairement
retardé la mise en oeuvre des tests pour
privilégier l'institut pasteur au
détriment du fabricant américain abbott
le procureur général considère que la
société abbott n'était pas en mesure de
répondre aux attentes françaises
après ces réquisitions de non lieu c'est
à la commission d'instruction de décider
du renvoi ou non du dossier devant la
cour de justice
les trois anciens ministres devrait être
fixé avant la mi juillet dans la sphère
du drac la cour d'appel de grenoble
alourdit les condamnations deux ans avec
sursis pour l'institutrice et 30 mille
francs d'amendé au lieu de 18 mois de
prison avec sursis infligée en septembre
dernier la directrice de l'établissement
qui avaient été relaxés désormais
déclaré coupable et condamné à 18 mois
avec sursis
enfin la ville de grenoble devra payer
une amende de 500 mille francs contre
cent mille en première instance après
l'attentât en 89 contre un dc-10 d'uta
qui avait fait 170 morts la cour
d'assises spéciale de paris jugera par
contumace c'est-à-dire en leur absence
six membres des services secrets libyens
qui seraient impliqués dans cet attentat
la profession de foi de lionel jospin
qui joue la carte de la famille
aujourd'hui le premier ministre a
confirmé abandonné la mise sous
condition de ressources des allocations
familiales
en contrepartie ils mettent en place
l'abaissement du plafond du quotient
familial par ailleurs différentes
dispositions ont été annoncées lors de
la conférence sur la famille
dispositions que nous détaille damien
thévenot jan cornet réunion de famille
ce matin à matignon autour du premier
ministre membre du gouvernement et
représentants d'associations
lionel jospin n'a pas encore dévoilé sa
réforme pourtant tous sont déjà au
courant
les allocations familiales vont être de
nouveau versé à tous les foyers dès le
deuxième enfant et sans condition de
ressources
satisfaction des familles
le premier ministre c'est un pas en
disant qu' il conserve l'universalité
des allocations familiales
nous nous faisons un pas en acceptant de
discuter du quotient familial
je pense que c'est un bon compromis pour
le gouvernement l'équation est simple
des allocations distribué à un nombre
plus important de famille c'est plus
d'argent dépensé donc pour rééquilibrer
les caisses il suffit de faire jouer la
fiscalité et notamment le quotient
familial
c'est un système qui autorise une
déduction d'impôt en fonction de la
composition de la famille cet avantage
fiscal est actuellement de 16 mille 380
francs par enfant
il sera abaissé à onze mille francs 400
mille familles vont être pénalisés en
majorité des foyers aisés pertes 6000
francs par an parmi les autres mesures
annoncées ce matin le versement des
allocations jusqu'à l'âge de 20 ans
contre 19 aujourd'hui une revalorisation
des aides au logement
enfin une extension de l'allocation de
rentrée scolaire dès le premier enfant
pour les familles modestes
toutes ces mesures ont convaincu
l'ensemble des associations
à une exception près familles de france
a boycotté la réunion
ce que le gouvernement annonçait une
grande politique familiale est bien pour
faire une grande politique familiale il
faut autre chose que des petites mesures
ponctuelles
au fond on est toujours dans la ligne de
juppé c'est à dire deux ou trois
bricoles des cacahuètes comme j'avais
dit cacahuètes pour les uns véritable
réforme pour les autres en tout cas
toutes les mesures annoncées aujourd'hui
entreront en vigueur dès l'année
prochaine
on l'aura compris la mesure fiscale sur
le quotient familial pénalise les
revenus les plus élevés mais favorable
aux classes moyennes
démonstration avec l'exemple de cette
famille de la banlieue parisienne ont
rencontré laurent bailly et bernie
mériaux
d'abord récupérer les deux enfants chez
la nounou et puis direction la maison
frédéric est salariée dans une société
d'informatique son mari travaille aussi
trente cinq mille francs pour vivre à
quatre c'est un revenu raisonnable
reconnaît la jeune maman
pourtant quand on lui a supprimé les
allocations familiales il ya six mois la
famille leclerc a dû réapprendre à
compter bah quand vous avez une somme
comprise entre 600 et 700 francs qui
arrive tous les mois
ça vous donne une soupape pour pouvoir
sortir pour pouvoir par exemple ça y est
là dès 18 heures ça vous permet de vous
aider dans l'alignement des enfants
parce qu'il soit encore faut-il les deux
couples se définit lui-même comme
faisant partie de la classe moyenne
une catégorie s'insurge-t-il trop
souvent mis à contribution les leclerc
ont perdu les allocations familiales
parce qu'ils étaient en fait juste au
dessus du revenu plafond on reconnaît
maintenant qu'ils n'ont rien de nabab
pour frédéric le retour de cet argent
dans le budget du foyer n'est que
justice
c'est une bonne chose enfin on va
retrouver ce qu'on avait avant
et c'est vrai que ça va toucher des
catégories qui seront sud nous peut-être
y avoir un petit peu plus d'équité
débuts en fait de rééquilibrage est
peut-être pas toujours les classes
moyennes qui vont être les premiers
touchés
l'inquiétude pourtant frédéric apprend
qu'en échange du retour de ces
allocations
le plafond du quotient familial lui va
baisser alors les leclerc se plonge dans
les calculs
on découvre au quotient familial on
s'était jamais penchée sur la question
je vais vous avouer que c'est pas très
clair maintenant d'après ce que j'ai
entendu il semble qu'on va quand même y
gagner et c'est ça qui compte
il gagne et oui plus de 8000 francs l'an
prochain car les leclerc ne gagnent pas
assez pour être touchés par la réforme
du quotient familial
frédéric rené leurs enfants peuvent
dormir sur leurs deux oreilles
on s'en souvient à l'entrée en vigueur
il ya quelques mois de ce dispositif
mettant sous conditions des allocations
familiales avait été accueilli plutôt
fraîchement dans l'opposition à
l'intérieur même du parti socialiste est
vivement critiqué par les communistes je
vous propose maintenant d'écouter ces
réactions satisfaction affichée pour les
communistes nouvelle augmentation de la
pression fiscale pour l'opposition la
aujourd'hui nous sommes satisfaits 7,7
que le premier ministre est annoncée qui
revenu sur la décision d'un dernière et
qu'il proposait de revoir le plafond du
quotient familial je trouve que ça va
dans le bon sens en réalité on voit bien
que le plat principal de la confiance
sur la famille c'était d'augmenter les
impôts moi je trouve que pour un
gouvernement qui il y a quelques
semaines quelques jours affirmé devant
la représentation nationale qui n'était
pas question d'augmenter la fiscalité
ça augure mal de l'avenir nlg spa
expliquer sinon justifier cet après midi
son abandon des allocations familiales
conditions déclarant que la fermeté ce
n'est pas de l'autisme nous l'écoutons
pour vous habituer à voir un
gouvernement qui entend ce gouvernement
vous l'avez constaté à l'occasion
d'événements récents ya des moments où
il sait dire non ou en tout cas il sait
dire qu'il faut trouver les solutions
c'est un gouvernement qui se montre
ferme la fermeté ça n'est pas l'autisme
la fermeté la constance dans la position
ça n'est pas refusé d'y aller la fermeté
ça n'est pas ne pas écouter et la
conviction ça n'est pas forcément ne
jamais changer il faut vous habituer à
une tentative de gouvernement plus
moderne et démocratique de ce pays le
premier ministre a donc opéré un
volte-face ce renonçait à une mesure qui
était mal comprises voir impopulaire en
même temps en jean michel carpentier en
jouant la carte de la famille chasse sur
les terres de l'opposition oui volte
face c'est vrai le premier ministre a
changé d'avis il revient sur une
décision qu'il avait brutalement annoncé
l'an dernier et qui était totalement
rejetée par les associations familiales
et aujourd'hui lionel jospin tentent de
profiter de ce revirement pour montrer
qu'il sait écouter les français et
rectifier les choses quand il se trompe
bref qu'il n'est pas prisonnier d'un
carcan idéologique
alors quand l'opposition affirme qu'il
augmente la pression fiscale on l'a
entendu le gouvernement répond qu'il
redistribue par l'impôt en faisant payer
les salaires les plus élevés à partir de
36 mille francs nets par mois
clin d'oeil à gauche tout en
rétablissant les allocations familiales
clin d'oeil aux classes moyennes et aux
centres car c'est là l'enjeu politique
de cette décision
avec la famille lionel jospin s'empare
d'un thème traditionnel de la droite
comme il l'avait déjà fait lundi dernier
avec un autre message d'autorité celui
là à propos de la délinquance des
mineurs
si l'on ajoute la fermeté employés pour
régler la grève d'air france cela fait
beaucoup de signes envoyés un électorat
orphelin de l'opposition après cela on
dire à matignon qu'on ne pense pas à
l'élection présidentielle merci jean
michel carpentier
les prix à la consommation français très
faible augmentation de 0,1 pour cent
mais sur les 12 derniers mois les prix
ont globalement augmenté de 1% en corse
nouvelles interpellations notamment dans
la région de bastia deux personnes
proches du nationaliste marcel lorenzoni
arrêté en février dernier par ailleurs
une perquisition a été faite au siège de
l'office de développement agricole et
rural de corse dans le cadre de
l'enquêté sur les détournements de fonds
michele finn cette note classée
confidentielle est elle à l'origine de
l'assassinât du préfet erignac
voilà l'une des hypothèse privilégiée
par les enquêteurs
c'est gérard bougrier ancien préfet de
police en corse qui rédige en octobre
dernier ce document jugé explosif une
liste de noms
les objectifs écrit le préfet sur
lesquels des investigations approfondies
pourraient être opérés par les services
spécialisés du ministère des finances
parmi ses objectifs des figures connues
du secteur agricole liée pour certains
aux nationalistes dans ces milieux là la
note aurait été perçue comme une
véritable déclaration de guerre de
l'état et donc de ses représentants
décembre 1997 locaux de l'office des
arte e mentale agricole et rural de la
corse des agriculteurs nationaliste
occupent les lieux
ce jour-là pour la première fois la note
confidentielle du préfet bougrier est
mystérieusement diffusé quelques jours
plus tard une autre liste va circuler en
corse mais il s'agit d'un faux tous les
noms ont été changés
ce matin les enquêteurs de la division
antiterroriste ont perquisitionné les
locaux de l'odarc ils ont interpellé
quatre des membres de l'office
ils veulent savoir comment la note a été
diffusé il cherche surtout qui pourrait
être l'auteur du faux à lyon à la veille
du match du mondial qui devra opposer la
corée du sud et le mexique plusieurs
milliers de commerçants et
d'agriculteurs ont bloqué l'autoroute
a72 blessés chez les gendarmes
au moment de l'évacuation d'une centaine
d'agriculteurs et de commerçants qui
avaient envahi la raffinerie de feyzin
au sud de la ville benoît gadret
philippe y avait à plusieurs reprises
des affrontements donc eu lieu cet après
midi sur l'autoroute a7 au sud de lyon
affrontements entre les forces de
l'ordre et plusieurs centaines de
manifestantes des commerçants des
artisans venus de toute la france
les gendarmes mobiles ont dû intervenir
pour évacuer la raffinerie de feyzin
deux d'entre eux ont été légèrement
blessés un colonel de gendarmerie a même
dû abandonner sa voiture aux
manifestants voici ce qu'il en reste
la manifestation présentée comme un
blocus de lyon était organisé par le
cdes hier syndicats connu pour ses
manières forme
le cdc a qui n'a de cesse de dénoncer la
pression fiscale qui pèse sur les
commerçants et artisans ne demande pas
d'argent on ne demande pas de prime et
on a les moyens de créer plus d'un
million d'emplois
mais il faut libéraliser le travail il
faut baisser les charges sociales on ne
peut pas continuer avec des gens qui
nous gouvernent qui ne sert que créer
des impôts il y à quelques minutes une
délégation est ressortie la préfecture
du rhône le barrage sur l'a7 est en
passe d'être levé l'autoroute fermée
depuis 15 heures devrait être réouverte
ces incidents ont provoqué d'importants
bouchons et perturbé la circulation dans
l'ensemble de la région lyonnaise
le maire de chablis déjà mises en examen
en janvier dernier après avoir été
accusé de viol
s'est vu notifié aujourd'hui de
nouvelles mises en examen pour
agressions sexuelles sur mineures écroué
pendant trois semaines
ce magnat avait été remise en liberté et
placé sous contrôle judiciaire à
versailles affrontements entre les
jeunes d'une cité des forces de police
qui venaient interpeller un homme de 25
ans une cinquantaine de jeunes ont pris
à partie les policiers
sept d'entre eux sont blessés ils
égalisent emmanuel bec encore choqué les
habitants de cette cité n'était pas
habitué à autant de violence 16h30 cet
après midi les policiers de versailles
interviennent pour interpeller un
individu une arrestation
particulièrement musclée selon plusieurs
témoins directs sont venus chercher ce
nul chercher chez lui et il se rentrer
en force et ils ont tapé tout le monde
la soeur les frères et ce sont robin
lyon il ya eu la rébellion une rébellion
des jeunes du quartier pour défendre
distillent leurs camarades
bilan sept policiers légèrement blessés
une des premières à intervenir
nouria la soeur du jeune homme
interpellé comme ils ont tâté mon petit
frère où je suis arrivé je leur ai dit
ne pas le frapper qu'il avait rien fait
qu'ils n'avaient rien à voir cette
histoire et policiers a dit j'avais
insulté je sais pas pourquoi il a sorti
ça et là 45 pouces et l'ami à coup il
m'a complètement éclatée l'ongle du
doigt moi je suis tombé par terre et
ensuite j'ai pas vu ce qu ils vraiment
ce qui s'était passé parce que j'étais
complètement pater j'étais en larmes ce
que j'avais très mal au ventre
ensuite j'ai récupéré ma nes à la à
l'école et là je tombe dans les pommes
enceinte de quatre mois et demi nous
rien a pris un coup au ventre
elle a décidé de porter plainte contre
les policiers des policiers qui de leur
côté déclare avoir été agressée par les
jeunes du quartier dès leur sortie de
l'immeuble
après la découverte d'un trésor par des
compagnons d'emmaüs dans un immeuble de
forbach la question est de savoir
maintenant à qui appartient ce butin
composé de pièces d'argent et de billets
de banque que les compagnons d'emmaüs
ont eu l'honnêteté de déposer ces sommes
chez un notaire alors qu'ils vivent dans
la précarité virginie fichet silva
gauthier leur univers un capharnaüm
derrière la gare de forbach
manu amis d'ee daniel trois compagnons
d'emmaüs habitué à débarrasser les
greniers
mais la semaine dernière derrière
poussière et toiles d'araignées c'est de
l'or qu'ils ont trouvé
alors là on a trouvé les sous à
l'intérieur ça c'était le jeudi le
samedi c'était là où il ya la planche
c'est là où est-ce qu'on a trouvée les
billets l'argent et après ça s'est passé
en bas dans la cave où on a trouvé le
reste en dessous des monnaies de
collection en or et argent des coupures
aux allemands des suisses
au total un magot estimé à plus de 500
mille francs
aujourd'hui décédés l'ancien
propriétaire avait abandonné la maison
il ya cinq ans laissant derrière lui ce
trésor il n'y aurait de tous j'en fais
quand même trop là on peut trouver à 13
ans a à côté de chez bourin et vous vous
n'en savez rien alors je dis pourquoi
pas chez nous le temps du club
à première vue dans l'appartement il n'y
avait pourtant rien n'a récupéré juste
trois bennes de détritus
alors quand au milieu le trésor est
apparu les trois garçons sont restés
abasourdis on est étonné d'avoir tout
trouver un
butin pareil le premier truc à quoi on a
pensé c'était de ramener tout ça à huit
responsables
on roule pas sur l'or mais on roule pas
sur l'or mais on a ce qu'il faut pour
vivre le reste c'est bon on est fiers
ils sont fiers aujourd'hui ils sont
fiers de pouvoir dire on est resté
honnête on n'a pas été tenté on est
resté sonné selon le code civil
un trésor est un bien enfouis découvert
par hasard et qui n'a pas de
propriétaire
si l'article 716 se vérifie manu daniel
et hamid auront droit à la moitié du
pactole mais il n'en demande pas tant
moi j'espère que la vie que la vie
change et que les gens nous regardent
notre oeil dise pas qu'on est des voyous
ça et puis on voudrait que on est à un
pied dans l'avenir futur quoi dû changer
un peu la vie on à l'actualité à
l'étranger avec à kiev cette longue
colonne de mineurs qui après 500 km de
marche sont entrés dans la ville
les gueules noires réclament d'être
enfin payer et de travailler dans de
meilleures conditions de sécurité sils
rabin
nous sommes arrivés créa mineurs dans
cette poule et ce n'est même pas un cri
de victoire ils marchent depuis 21 jours
sur les routes du prêt n'est sous un
soleil de plomb ils ont traversé la
moitié du pays d'est en ouest
le casque sur la tête et les mains vides
car ils n'ont plus rien et depuis
longtemps pour faire entendre leurs
doléances et leurs revendications les
mineurs du bassin du donbass en ukraine
n'avait pas comme leurs collègues russes
le transsibérien a bloqué alors ils ont
entrepris cette marche longue de plus de
500 kilomètres ils partaient chaque
matin 6h et s'arrêter après huit heures
de marche
comme il n'avait plus rien ils ont vécu
dans les villes et villages traversés de
la solidarité et de la charité de gens
aussi pauvres que melvin mois de salaire
qu'on m'a pas payé je veux les recevoir
en entier voit la maison c'est déjà
arrivé que pendant deux semaines
on pouvait même plus acheter de teint
frais on vivait un sac c'était comme ça
pas payé depuis huit mois et
condamné par une balbutiante économie de
marché qu'ils ne comprennent pas chez
nous dans notre état il y a trois cent
soixante de banques
on n'a pas besoin de ces banques
commerciales il faut les partager avec
nous c'est bon si le président le fait
il pourra payer nos salaires pour
l'instant le gouvernement et le
président ukrainien leonid kuchma reste
muet les mineurs eux ont décidé de
rester jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient pillés
la crise au kosovo le groupe de contact
sur l'ex-yougoslavie met en demeure le
président milosevic de faire cesser la
violence sous peine de sanctions ces
déclarations interviennent aujourd'hui
alors que la france a décidé d'envoyer
des tonnes de matériel en albanie pour
venir en aide aux réfugiés qui fuient le
kosovo depuis le début des affrontements
65000 personnes au total auraient fui
leur domicile
un pont aérien de l'onu devrait
acheminer des secours d'urgence à rome
yasser arafat que l'on dit très affaibli
a été reçue en audience privée par le
pape jean paul ii le président de
l'autorité palestinienne a offert au
chef de l'église un bas relief
représentant la ville de bethléem
il invitait le saint-père à venir fêter
sur place le jubilé de l'an 2000 le pape
aurait réagi positivement à cette
invitation
retour au mondial cet après midi à lens
le danemark rencontre l arabie saoudite
ces deux équipes font partie du groupe
de la france le danemark a battu
l'arabie saoudite 1 0 florent gautreau
un monument pour des cons
c'est toujours impressionnant michael
laudrup 33 ans reçoit un bouquet de 100
roses pour sa 100e sélection
félicitations mais derrière mickaël la
relève danoise est déjà prête
c'est le petit frère brian laudrup qui
fait le spectacle le benjamin joue du
talon comme d'autres du violon
l'entraîneur brésilien de l'arabie
saoudite apprécié en connaisseur mais il
préfère lui les francs tireurs
la frappe de eran seule occasion
saoudienne en première période et
détourné de justesse par schmeichel et
en face il faudra tout le sang froid du
gardien saoudien al b aiea pour contrer
la tentative de marque reaper le géant
danois un mètre 91 pour 83 kg n'hésite
jamais à venir prêter main forte à ses
attaquants et il sera récompensé en
deuxième mi temps c'est lui qui marque
de la tête le but qui permet au danemark
de l'emporter
un but qui fait du danemark l'ennemi
numéro un de la france dans ce groupe c
on disait les danois vieillissant et
triste ils sont solides et joyeux
chapeau bas messieurs
et puis le paraguay la bulgarie ont fait
match nul cet après midi à montpellier
partant maintenant marseille ou dans
moins d'une demi heure les bleus
devraient entrer dans la danse marseille
est la patrie de zinedine zidane ou le
leader de l'équipe de france est née il
ya 26 ans les quartiers nord de la ville
l'ont vu grandir et on imagine l'émotion
et la pression que ressentent
aujourd'hui ses amis zidane symbole de
la réussite possible
zizou comme l'appelle encore ses amis
d'enfance thibault de barbeyrac
jean-louis querrec tout l'après midi ils
ont tué le temps en jouant au football
il y a dix ans où ces mêmes arcade
zinedine zidane était à leur classe
dylan enfant de la castellane l'idole
les quartiers nord de marseille dans le
quartier tout le monde attend avec
anxiété le premier match des bleus et la
performance de zidane sur le terrain il
sera le chef d'orchestre
ici il est l'exemple à suivre
nous a montré qu'à bien qu il ya de
l'espoir c'est lui qui a franchi le
premier la porte et quoi et je crois il
a donné faire beaucoup d'un tronc
d'arbre arrivés le 23
là vraiment une influence aussi juste
des paroles janvier - faites dans les
médias non le gîte ou non mais moi
personnellement et je fais de la boxe et
je veux c'est grâce à lui grâce à lui
aussi la nouvelle vague
le club de foot de la cité a pu rhône
est un club qui ce soir aurais tu aimé
installer un grand écran au milieu des
immeubles refusé ce sera donc chacun
chez soi devant sa télé mais après le
match en cas de victoire de l'équipe de
france
ils promettent de faire beaucoup
beaucoup de moules et retrouvant
maintenant près de l'hôtel de ville dans
plein coeur de marseille françois
brabant espérant que le vent ne va pas
gâcher la fête quelle est l'ambiance à
quelques minutes du coup d'envoi
vous savez béatrice je ne sais pas si de
mémoire de marseillais on se souvient
d'un vendredi soir avec un soleil pareil
ou sur le vieux port sur la canebière il
n'y ait quasiment pas un marseillais ils
sont tous partis
ils sont soixante mille au moins autour
du stade est déjà un peu dans le stade
vélodrome
ils sont plusieurs milliers également
devant l'écran géant installé sur la
plage du prado vous savez qu'avec le
mistral qui souffle fort et qui a
soufflé toute la journée d'aujourd'hui
on a cru que ces retransmissions
publiques ne pourrait avoir lieu elles
ont lieu et le public marseillais attend
cette retransmission
et puis bien sûr et bien il ya nous sur
le sur le vieux port on est quasiment
les derniers et bas nous aussi on a très
hâte que ça commence
l'équipe de france devra affronter les
bafana bafana d'afrique du sud vous le
savez leur entraîneur et français nelson
mandela suit de très près la destinée de
ces joueurs qui pour certains sont nés à
soweto
portrait de son leader le capitaine la
db avec florent gautreau et philippe
deslandes
c'était écrit luca sera bébé était né
pour ça pour devenir l'idole de tout un
peuple
depuis deux ans il est le capitaine noir
d'une sélection enfin accepté sur la
scène internationale son destin se
confond avec celui de l'équipe nationale
sa vie symbolise tout le chemin parcouru
par l'afrique du sud en quelques années
les bafana bafana comme on surnomme en
zoulou les joueurs sud africains ont
trouvé leur leader luca sera db est un
modèle pour les autres joueurs
un exemple pour ses entraîneurs
l'histoire de lucas commence ici à
soweto où il est né il ya 29 ans le
centre-ville de johannesburg est alors
réservé aux blancs des noirs vivent à
quelques kilomètres cantonné dans des
bicoques en briques et en tôle ondulée
en 90 nous avions rencontré luc il était
déjà footballeur et il rêvait d'une
carrière internationale
il avait les cheveux longs il habitait
chez ses parents il ne gagnait presque
rien en revoyant ces images nous cassera
db mesure à quel point il a changé en
même temps que son pays doit bons et de
mauvais mots coûte mais c'est bien par
se retourner sur son passé et d'être
fiers de ce qu'on est aujourd'hui nous a
tué
pourquoi cette chose-là prouve que dans
la vie on peut s'en sortir parce que il
ne s'agit pas seulement de football il
s'agit de ma vie
non
vous êtes aujourd'hui ça va de mieux en
mieux avec la libération du président
monsieur mandela
tout s'est amélioré notre équipe
nationale est né à cette époque et on a
essayé de réunir les blancs et les noirs
et ça se passe plutôt bien
luca sera db puise dans son histoire
un optimisme contagieux et de vraies
raisons d'espérer
car quand la db est heureux c'est toute
l'afrique du sud qui a le sourire
ainsi donc se termine ce journal je vous
en rappelle le principal titre c'est
bien sûr dans quelques minutes l'équipe
de france qui affrontera les bafana
bafana d'afrique du sud pour leur
premier match en du monde le stade le
vélodrome de marseille
soixante mille supporteurs pour
accueillir les deux équipes dans la cité
phocéenne
l'attaquant thierry henry remplace ce
christophe dugarry le match est
retransmis à 20h50 sur 3 3 dans un
instant la météo présentée par nathalie
rihouet suivi du point route présentée
par valérie maurice de master dans thé
ou café
catherine ceylac recevra à l'écorner je
vous remercie de votre attention
excellente de fin de soirée sur france 2
oh